اعلانات تسريح بدات مطلع السنه وجاءت اولا
من شركه صغيره ومتوسطه ولكن موجه التسريح
الان طلت عمالقه التكنولوجيا مثل متى
وامازون واوبر واريبيان بي ونتفليكس
ومايكروسوفت لدرجه انه تم تاسيس موقع
الكتروني ليف صوت اف واي ي يرصد كل
الوظائف المفقوده التي تجاوز عددها 150
الف وظيفه هذه السنه ورغم ان لكل شركه
اسبابها الخاصه الى ان هناك عوامل مشتركه
على القطاع اولا العديد من تلك الشركات
عينت الاف الموظفين خلال الجائحه استجابه
لطلب متزايد على خدماتها واملتا بان يدوم
اسلوب المعيشه الرقميه مات مثلا عينت اكثر
من 15 الف موظفا في اول تسعه شهور من
السنه الجاريه ولكن قبل اسابيع اعلن مرض
ذكر
انه سيسرح احد عشر الف موظفا اي 13% من
القوه العامله
امازون بدولها اعلنت الاستغناء عن عشره
الاف موظف في اكبر عمليه تسريح في تاريخها
على هذه الشركات ان تواجهها الواقع فهم
واجهوا عده فصول من تراجع الارادات والكل
يتساءل ماذا ستفعل الشركه لتعامل مع
الاداء الصعب والتحديات والنتائج المخيبه
ولكن ايضا ماذا ستفعل استعدادا لسنه
القادمه التي ستكون صعبه والعديد من
الشركات اخذت خطوات للتسريح منها تويتر
وامازون ومجتمع المستثمرين يودوا ان تكون
الشركات اكثر انضبا وتشوفا
عامل اخر وهو ازمه تكلفه المعيشه وارتفاع
معدل التضخم هذا بدوره ادى الى تراجع
الاعلانات عبر الانترنت والمنصات الرقميه
كما ان بعض تغيرات في قواعد الخصوصيه لدى
شركه مثل ابل ضربت سوق الاعلانات وفي مجال
التكنولوجيا الخدمه الماليه انطلقت
الشركات ايضا ضربه من ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده
المستثمرون ايضا زاد من ضغطهم على الشركات
لخفض تكاليفها
قامت العديد من هذه الشركات بالاستثمار
للنمو على المدى الطويل ولم تهتم بالربحيه
اعتقد ان هذه الاستراتيجيه انتهتماما ويجب
على الشركات اعاده ترتيب اولوياتها
والتركيز على المشروعات والمبادرات الاهم
فقط والعمل لنمو اعمالها وتحسين الاداء
الماليه لان المستثمرين لن يصبر 10 سنوات
كي يرون نتيجه الاستثمارات يجب ان يتخذوا
القرارات الصعبه
الى مصر الذي فصل نصف موظفي تويتر هو من
انصار ضروره خفض التكاليف في شركته
الجديده التي تواجه تحديات في زياده
ارباحها واضافه مستخدم جدد كما يرى البعض
ان رواتب ومزايا الموظفين في القطاع
التكنولوجي غير مستدامه واعلى من غيرها من
القطاعات
على المستثمرين في مجال التكنولوجيا
الاجابه تعتمد على حجم وطبيعه الشركه اذا
كان التسريح مجرد خطوه اخرى في طريقه
انهيار الشركه فمثل هذه الاخبار التي تعيد
الثقل المستثمرين ولكن اذا كان الهدف من
التسريح خفض التكليف فهذا قد يكون مرحب به
من قبل المستثمرين لانه قد يؤدي الى تحسن
الربحيه لندن